[Music]
Freedom
personal freedom is fundamental to who
we are as Americans there's nothing more
important nothing more sacred that's
been the work of my first turn to fight
for our democracy this shouldn't be a
red or blue issue
to protect our rights to make sure that
everyone in this country is treated
equally and that everyone is given a
fair shot at making it
[Music]
but you know around the country Maggie
extremists are lining up to take on
those Bedrock freedoms cutting Social
Security that you've paid for your
entire life while cutting taxes from the
very wealthy dictating what health care
decisions women can make Banning books
and telling people who they can love all
while making it more difficult for you
to be able to vote
[Music]
when I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less freedom more rights are fewer I
know what I want the ancient to be and I
think you do too
this is not a time to be complacent
[Music]
that's why I'm running for re-election
I know America
I know we're good and decent people
I know we're still a country that
believes in honesty and respect and
treating each other with dignity
That We're a nation where we give hate
no Safe Harbor we believe that everyone
is equal that everyone should be given a
fair shot to succeed this country
[Music]
every generation Americans have faced a
moment when they have to defend
Democracy stand up for our personal
freedom stand up for the right to vote
in our civil rights
[Music]
and this is our moment
[Applause]
so if you're with me go to joebiden.com
let's finish this job I know we can
because this is the United States of
America there's nothing suddenly nothing
we cannot do if we do it together
[Music]